ja was in dieser legislaturperiode uns
alle erwartet ihr habt gerade die grünen
angesprochen ist wenn wir uns mit einem
post ansehen einer jungen grünen
abgeordneten wir schauen hier einmal
rein es ging um die bänder dem mann
tragen musste heute im bundestag und das
hier bei instagram hat die junge grüne
politikerin hohle pathos
gericht thüringen gestern geführt noch
als georg gegen zu viele national
schlagen argumentiert jetzt musst du das
hässlichste festivalbändchen aller
zeiten tragen aber zeigt an dass man
zweig ist und deshalb kann ich
ausnahmsweise damit leben für die
westlichste festivalbändchen
große aufregung auch im netz über diesen
post ja das ist einfach ein bizarrer
einstand als bundestagsabgeordnete also
sie sitzt im deutschen bundestag der
befindet sich im reichstagsgebäude über
dem reichstagsgebäude steht dem
deutschen volk und dieses volk hat sich
nun mal eine flagge gegeben diese flagge
steht in deutschland für demokratie
das ist keine frage der diktatur oder
sonst was diese frage steht für die
deutschen institutionen auch die
garantieren dass wir in einer demokratie
und in einem rechtsstaat leben auch wir
im deutschen bundestag was man das nicht
jeder gleich patriotisch ist dass manche
menschen in deutschland auch deutsche
natürlich einen gewissen inneren
zwiespalt haben beim thema patriotismus
auch angesichts der deutschen geschichte
ist ja völlig klar aber dass man diese
flaggen als hässlichste aller zeiten
bezeichnet das verstehe ich nicht gibt
es irgendeinen anderen staat in dem der
vater vielleicht lieber im parlament
sitzen würde und wenn man schon sagt das
hässlichste bändchen aller zeiten was
ist denn mit den ganzen diktaturen die
findet ob ich heute weniger schlimm ich
frage mich wenn man die flagge so sehr
ablehnend lehnt man auch die
institutionen dann ab sie gehört hier
nun einer zentralen institution an also
ich glaube da haben die grünen noch
wirklich klärungsbedarf und man muss
aber auch sagen sie gibt nicht wieder
was alle in der grünen-fraktion denken
cem özdemir hat vor einigen jahren sich
ganz klar bekannt zur deutschen flagge
hat gesagt das ist eine frage der
vielfalt das eine flagge der demokratie
und selbstverständlich ist ja nicht
bereit diese flagge eigentlichen
rechtsextremen zu überlassen aber genau
das tut frau berta wenn sie heute an
ihrem ersten richtigen tag bundestag
natürlich so etwas in die welt in der
künftigen regierungsfraktionen auch das
wird noch mal spannend sein wie die
grünen land damit umgehen mit solchen
diskussionen auch innerhalb der eigenen
fraktion mit all den jungen grünen die
damit eingerückt sind holen grenze wenn
es den eindruck gewinnen sie denn lieber
beiden klassen bereich festival heute
gewesen nachdem bundestag vielleicht
sagt 'du siehst du vielleicht